Speaker 1: This is such a funny moment from Queen
Elizabeth's funeral yesterday. I had no interest
in the queen's funeral. I didn't watch any of
the queen's funeral. I just don't think it's
not interesting to me. I don't think it's really
interesting to my audience. Very few people even
emailed me, you know, we get hundreds and hundreds
of emails a day and barely any about the Queen's
funeral. No requests to cover it. Couple of emails
from people saying the monarchy is outdated,
with which I would agree. But this is just a
really, really funny moment. So global media
covered the Queen's funeral and this included
Australian media. And there is an unbelievable,
dare I say, Kafka esque moment where the new
Prime Minister of the UK arrives, Liz Truss,
and the Australian media covering it sort of says
we don't really know who's showing up now. We're
kind of getting to the dregs. I think they use the
pointy end or something like that and then they're
told apparently in like an earpiece that that's
actually the British Prime Minister, Liz Truss.
And it's just an unbelievable moment. Check this
out. Instantly going viral and I just love it.
Speaker 2: It's just not hard to identify
maybe even minor royals and members of the
I can't identify them.
Speaker 1: But yeah,
these could be minor royals and.
Speaker 2: Unfortunately they look like they
will be most appealing traits. It's hard to.
Speaker 1: See. These are just locals
of some kind looking.
Speaker 2: At the backs of
their heads. But I think we are now getting
to the pointy end, as they say of the was
I'm just told that was Liz Truss, the new Prime
Minister. In the distance that we can look like.
Speaker 1: And I love the little add on of in
the distance like she's so far away from the
shot like way way, way over that it could have
been anybody. It just happens to be Liz Truss,
someone at the tell us that that's who it
was. It is truly an unbelievable moment. And,
you know, there is no big point here other than
how funny this is. Other than this is all such a
charade. It is all just such a charade. And of
course, everybody should get to have whatever
service and funeral and whatever that they want
and that the family wants and everything. We're
not trying to deny that to anybody, but the entire
pomp and circumstance around this funeral has just
been something else. And this just sort of the
cherry on top, minor royals of some kind. It's
the dregs. It's the bottom of the barrel. Oh, it's
the British prime minister. Very far away, out in
the distance. All right. If you are if you're
curious about that clip, you can you'll find it
on our Twitter at David Pakman show. You can also
follow me on Twitter at David Pakman. We're going
to take a quick break. We have a lot of very
important things coming up on today's program.